well done you've made it through to the
end and you've learned a lot about
prototyping and user research now that
you've learned how to iterate how to
bring on team members and how to share
your project you're ready to do the work
on your own app remember that this work
can be done many times over to get
yourself to a great finished product
that you should expect to throw out many
early versions to find one that
resonates with your users once you've
done this work you'll still need to
actually build your app but that part of
it will go way more smoothly with this
prep work complete by listening to users
before you build the app itself you can
be sure you're creating a great
experience for them now get out there
and start prototyping